John hi nice to meet you nice to meet
you as well bumblebee is so much fun how
do you feel about joining the
transformers universe oh it's a
tremendous honor
I think this installment especially
because bumblebee is a new take an
origin tale on this universe the
animation of the Transformers themselves
have been changed the style in which
they transform has been changed the
story is a little bit more in-depth it's
a it's a heartfelt tale about friendship
with using transforming robots of the
background yes
was it fun to go back to 1987 and is
there any eighties trends that you're
just so happy are not here right now 20
yeah all of all of my choices to decide
what was cool I in a ladies i rocked a
high-top fade i rocked the rayon hammer
polkadot pants airbrushed overalls i'm
very very happy that were at a different
speed but it was it was fun to go back
and see all that stuff i keep telling
everybody I wasn't I didn't have the
luxury of going in Charlie's room or
Charlie's uh memos room when that that's
where all like the real 80s stuff was
culturally the pop culture stuff I saw
big tape drives macro computers yes
everything military pre 1987 so now that
actually was really period correct it
just wasn't like pop culture fun yeah
what is that the biggest challenge just
transitioning from of course WWE star
but getting into acting was there one
thing in particular just being able to
learn learn the environment yeah so
they're they're very similar WWE we we
tell stories a narrative of good versus
evil it's exactly what we're doing here
it's just a different form you're on
this huge screen in which the smallest
action can leave the biggest impact or
nww in this little tiny ring yes huge
arena so you have to be huge and I'm
very fortunate enough in the choices
that I made to work with very talented
directors who I also have great rapport
with and I I relayed this problem hey
you're gonna walk out to me a lot and be
like hey that was a 10 give me a 1
and it's just about being open and
honest with your weaknesses and flaws
especially the person making the movie
saying hey my goal is the same as yours
I want to make this good don't be afraid
to tell me I suck and teach me how to
get better yeah so like I said it's it's
a it's a little bit of a negative but at
the same time I'm communicating with the
people making the movie so it ends up
being okay yeah well we get to see you
return to reality television anyway I
don't know uh
Never Say Never but I've taken major
goals to reprieve ax ties my life yeah
III just prefer to be criticized or
praised on my body of work and I I don't
take away anything from unscripted
television I think it is wildly
entertaining because it's a reason that
it's on TV but I'm just I'm just one of
those folks who needs to have some
personal space and nowadays it seems
like people can be on all the time I'm
just one of those folks that enjoys time
away from that and it makes me not only
miss it but it makes me excited for the
next opportunity for it so I don't know
I never say never but I'm not sure
you